right yeah there's like a windy day and
that's it uh
there's even no wind it's just normal is
there a noise is it i make the noise but
that's it
oh my god but does anybody believe you
if no semen comes out
does anybody believe yeah you can fake
it all the time
you you you first of all i don't think
males are motivated to fake you know
what i mean
oh i know i've been there really
anything to get me out of the damn
bedroom dude i would do it
there's a lot packed into that statement
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
[Music]
so well here we are
when we introduce who's in our culture
corner well look man we got
we had to get as cultural as we could
that's what we had to do we had to call
in some big hitters
and me when you say culture i sort of
think like a bacterial culture
oh yeah that's what it is today yeah
good that's what i thought
yeah i'm a resistant strain i think
cancel culture
that's the first thing that comes to my
mind
[Laughter]
it's so stupid and so primitive and so
crazy
it's really it's the french revolution
behavior guillotine can it go away
though you think
yeah i think so yeah culturally
pendulums always swing back well the
problem is that when you when you get
into these um scapegoating you know
group scapegoating mob behavior
eventually the mob themselves is up on
the guillotine
so it starts eating itself no one's pure
enough i know if you saw where alyssa
milano was getting attacked by
rose mcgowan i'm like well here it comes
yeah here it comes the the most woke are
getting
i'm woker and boom you're dead you stole
my metoo movement
yeah it's like yes you're at it it's
pretty crazy
yeah they went at each other because uh
one of these
my buddy hooked up with one of these
ladies in a motel hallway i bet i could
guess which one
um but like actually hooked up in the
hallway
or i think it yeah it really escalated
out of the hallway and then moved to
other rooms
your friend needs to be careful you know
what i mean this wasn't recently though
i'm just saying it seems like stuff is
like there's no no
statute on these things like they oh
yeah yeah no but i think she started it
i'm saying it doesn't matter really he
was looking for the restroom
yeah he was looking for the restroom
she's like hey how about i blow you
i'd whoa now you're not you're taking it
down i don't even know man
i'm just saying things escalated like i
said that happened yeah yeah the [ __ ]
banned it
there's a [ __ ] ban she was a [ __ ]
bandit all over comic-con one year it
was nuts wow
and were people scared no no i was at
first
until i got blown he was the object of
said
um oh you were a victim victim a bigger
partner victim i mean
if you wanted classified as being a
victim i guess but yeah she
i was he was attacked yeah was he really
how so
dude she okay i was with some people
that i actually knew and like i was
with this young lady who like we weren't
boyfriend girlfriend but we were like
sounds like a rape setting the
groundwork
okay this this other girl and she got
[ __ ] hammered we had hooked up and
stuff like like we were there but we
were in the early stage
and she got like hammered like
concerning white girl wasted
and then she's like uh she's grooming
her subject where are you staying say
grooming
yeah where are you staying i go i'm
staying at the [ __ ] hilton i don't
remember
what hotel she's like oh um i'm gonna
walk you back to your room and i was
like
i don't really think that's thank you
though but
um i'm good park
person or something park rangers yeah at
comic-con
yeah at comic-con yeah i'm gonna help
you hide your food in boxes before you
go to bed
and by the way andrew will back me up
with this i'm like not exactly like
party king it was probably like 10 p.m
you know i was like really do i need to
be watching is she attractive she's
by no means unattractive but she's not
my type she's first off mike has a thing
she's a
blonde white girl which is great and all
but that's not i like
you and i've talked about this yes i
like we have the same type ethnic
big ass like very petite titties but
like nice big juicy legs
this girl was a um more of like a like
she was an attractive but like a like a
sorority girl attractive like you know
like abercrombie type
thing right okay and uh poor mike mic
that's really sad
i'm on the edge of my seat i hope you're
all right with all this and i go uh you
know what i'm i'm good
really on the edge of my seat because
you broke one of the rails
i'm like you're an old chair that's
disgusting
i don't need like a walk home i'm i'm
okay and she said
no i'm gonna walk you home i'm gonna
suck your [ __ ]
and i go wow good for her that's so
but that's so when you're in that it
sounds great in the moment though that's
so dramatic you're like
is this girl setting me up for what's a
prank show
because a seemingly normal non-crazy
girl goes no i'm gonna follow you home
and suck your [ __ ] you're like wait wait
wait
what bizarro world am i in spunked maybe
with ashton gutcher yeah yeah um so like
wow she follows me could be a thing now
really good you're on spunk dude
you're not busting a nut tonight randy
got you man
you're on spawn but he doesn't jump out
so you're screwing your hands
down enjoy your blue balls now
people say we're heading towards
idiocracy it'd be a perfect show for
that
but that's not idiocracy that's just i
mean i'd watch that like celebrity
guy you got the blow job though she
follows me home
she follows me home yeah i like changes
in all this i'm not even getting blown
yeah she changes the subject and
and uh she follows me home and i'm like
okay so i finally get to my hotel room
i'm like this is weird
i'm like all right good night she said
no i'm i'm gonna follow you in and i'm
gonna suck your [ __ ] and i don't want
anything i just
she's like i really wanna blow you and i
go this is so
strange you said that out loud yes i go
this is very peculiar you know that
right and she's like
she's like just now she's like punking
me she's like what are you a [ __ ] like
i wanted
yeah so i go okay so i open the door
and i walk in like maybe 10 feet
and she just starts i have like a belt
on and everything and she just starts
[ __ ]
yanking on my pants and i'm like whoa
well so i undo my belt
and she completes the the thing and i
complete the uh the
blow job his version of the employer
i uh i i arrived and uh is part of the
deal
and she like sits there and on her knees
she goes
just hug me and i go oh oh
oh you mean she wasn't all mentally sane
she didn't have her [ __ ] together man
then think well then i got the chills in
here so i do but like an awkward hug
like you would hug your aunt you know
like i was like
like an ironing board
and she got up in after like 45 seconds
of hugging she got up and she
left and i never saw or talked to that
girl again wow
now a mike was sexually abused when he
was like 12.
i would say that was another sexual
abuse act she found a right good victim
who didn't see it as an abuse because
he'd been abused before and didn't
understand that it was an abuse back
when he was 12
and she raped him wow you classified
that as rape
that was a that was a difference here's
the story the man
i'm seeing what the doctor you
classifies
i know what you do unwanted sexual
contact with
per you know with i mean i if i flip the
script a male does that but flip the
script and it's way worse typically
though because
let me be clear at any point at any
point there even though i was kind of
resisting
i could have physically said stop it and
put my hand out and been like
leave now or there should be trouble a
woman oftentimes doesn't have that
luxury and that you know it does make it
scary for her i agree and now i'm saying
that you should have
done something different i'm just saying
that's what that was
yeah and that's interesting i'm glad it
didn't hurt him or traumatized him or
anything it's you know i thought the
story didn't go elsewhere and then she
went like door to door
sucking guys off well because you call
her the suck man okay so i didn't know
her name
it only takes one time to be a suck man
to brendan
you're not a bandit you're not sucked
dude i start telling the story
like you know back back to love line
back to kevin b i start telling the
story and everything and i didn't know
this woman's name
and people should have been like who was
she i was like well i know she was
so-and-so's publicist because she kept
coming that's why she was at comic con
and then people go and they're like oh i
as the story grew
many men were like oh i i know that girl
yes
uh she's she's predator she's a
wienerman she'd be a predator
yeah that wiener banshee yeah for real
wiener banshee
sick that's my new band yeah you want to
be in wiener banshee
you see what's messed up is if you're a
man if somebody tries to suck your
wiener
it's right there it's it's hanging out
of your body whereas if you try to do
that you can't really
to a lady you got to kind of go look for
their wiener a little you can't it's
just not
there's no they're not the same yes
right yeah you have that really
your penis is just kind of hanging
around waiting to be a victim it's like
a drunk guy at a park you know at a gay
park someone's just take advantage of
them yeah
it's always there yeah it's always just
like it's ready for the accident yeah
it's just imagine if people's women's
vaginas was hanging out about seven
inches from their body people
or if it was like on their chin you know
like it'd be so easy to just like
[ __ ] walk and be like [ __ ] yeah
you like that yeah oh my god
so nobody ever takes that little you
know that in a you got to look at it to
scale or whatever it's called
would you guys get a lot of callers on
love line who who didn't realize it was
something like that yes
who didn't realize they've been raped
his original sexual abuse i had to like
kind of bring him
into getting into focus for him i never
talked about it ever
i never opened up about it and then i
finally did on love line i was like 30.
and i was like do you hear these stories
every night this is one of those stories
right it's just you're a male and you
don't you know
and that you were how old it was i was
like you to a babysitter right
no she was my my cousin's older my
cousin was like a senior in high school
and this was her friend she was like
already graduated high school she was
like 19 20. and i was a beautiful lady
no he has a name for her the mustachioed
succubus
because she had yeah it was like similar
to brendan's facial hair
i think i bet on her on the preakness
once actually
handsome young lady that one though i do
feel like a certain
different level of sensitivity to a lot
of these girls who say
like i didn't say no but i didn't want
to do it and i felt
like the power difference right made me
it was intimidating
and so a lot of guys they don't
necessarily comprehend that i when they
say that i go oh my god you're
i get it i was 13 though yeah i mean but
i was very horny
would think that's cool but when they
actually experience it it's not so cool
with a 20 year old
yeah i remember i was a bus boy and uh
here we go
yeah so you must have been 16 at least
no man i started early bus boy and i was
bus boy probably 14.
well i was probably one of the 30 or 15
best bus boys in tucson
tucson yeah this is my neighbor
louisiana then i lived in tucson for
one year during high school and that's
when i was really good
you you've like really educated me about
the south oh yeah i rely on you for some
of that oh thanks man
yeah there's definitely a lot of uh it's
still the same you know
nothing's changed as the last time we
talked earlier
no updates for dr drew on the south not
really something and i'm talking about
you know i've spent a lot of time in
atlanta and nashville
nashville in south greenville and places
like that that's not what we're talking
about yeah we're talking
about molasses country theo's sound yeah
we're talking where it gets real risque
you know we're talking the stray animal
belt
um where you throw gerbils out of the
back of a car
they're hamsters hamsters whatever we
sold them
okay but you know what the same thing
happens in the city like everyone
they're like i've been to los angeles
you know i went to hollywood in highland
and i went to rodeo drive and you're
like
go to commerce yeah i got moles persian
guy at a starbucks it's like
different it's different though you go
to like okay that counts everyone's like
i've been to new york city i went to the
statue of liberty i was like go to the
south bronx
yeah that's also new york it's very
different you know go buy some smack
over there on freaking b
and second and b you know it is kind
that's kind of an interesting topic no
one ever discusses by the way
how these these environments and cities
and regions get sort of
a character and we just accept that
that's just how it is
when in reality the real lived
experience if you get out there with
people is very very different
i'm sort of interested in that and uh
you've
enlightened me on the south yeah well i
think that's a big problem we have right
now is a lot of people just not
understanding what it's like in certain
places that's exactly right
and there's no way that's exactly why it
interests me right yeah
some man yesterday i met a white man
outside yesterday and he was telling me
that you changed your race since i last
saw you you keep talking about white
people is that you white
oh i mean i'm you know i'm trying to
we're not sure yeah okay
okay right now yeah that's good that's
why it's good
let me see let me see your [ __ ] i'm
trying to get that i'll tell you mike's
white
he's jewish i think right i'm trying to
get that sba loan dude
[Laughter]
um so uh and this man said they were
trying to come out with a virtual
reality
so you could see what other people's
reality is like oh that's interesting
so to get an idea that's a great idea
because people are always like oh people
from the south they're racist y'all you
know and
it's just not the truth i'm just getting
so tired of hearing it
and then but it's just people's
perceptions they just can't understand
what this other
whether you know other places if they
really do an ai thing like that it'd be
great like
here's the you know theo's neighbors
perspective h5
yeah here it is age 12. here it is in
high school yeah and give those
experiences to us to be
fantastic but also people's experiences
are based off what they see in the media
as well
now it is it's a big big big problem i
think
i think we're slowly coming out of that
i think the cove had taught people
uh that they're just trying to [ __ ] with
us yeah but
you're you're looking at you're looking
at like social media and like
internet media look at cable news i'm
talking but even that too like
divorce yourself from that social media
is a nightmare look at mainstream
real commercial media whether it be
reality shows or sitcoms and things like
that
whenever like like look at jersey shore
like vicky gonvilson if you've never
been to the northeast now
vicky's my friend how did you really
even know i just love her name so i just
thought about it it's a great name
it's like i get my all those oc
housewives man yeah i get my name
be careful it's like i just want my news
from vicki gunvald and i want it
straight from her
look at that face she's awesome hey but
here's the deal
that's whoa is she awesome drew is she
is she [ __ ]
is she is she teddy roosevelt no i mean
she also
no or she kind of like easy to get along
with like let's not
i like her okay fine she might be a nice
person she's not [ __ ] awesome
yeah that's his friend though daddy is
going hard in the paint i'm also a fan
of this lovely we
10 towards hyperbole drew let's say like
oh i'm going to see this
phil i don't want to talk [ __ ] but peter
will be like i'm going to see this band
on friday it's going to be great susan
and i are going i was like
[ __ ] you you guys no they're great
they're amazing i was like true stop
let's let's pause let's rewind
is that band great or are or did they
come on love line and they were really
nice to you and you want to go support
them because yeah you're right
that's hollywood great yeah hollywood
after a while it's like oh yeah you got
to meet this great guy you know
and then it's a bad guy yeah or you know
a lot of things
this is his credit this is honestly and
this is real he doesn't realize that
people treat him special he doesn't
realize he's a celebrity he doesn't
realize he's like big
drew is very unaware of that he and uh
it's a compliment thank god because he's
very he's very hungry
but but drew will say [ __ ] like dude
um and this is like at the opening of it
you know he goes you gotta go see
the the book of mormon on broadway and i
was like
okay yeah uh do you have a thousand
bucks to loan me and it and and
can i get in can i just like oh don't
just go backstage it's easy it's very
easy
you just go backstage and then you talk
to matt and trey and then everyone
i'm like drew what it was josh it was
joshua you know exactly yeah that was
like true
oh wow that's not how it works for me
that's how it works for you you know he
doesn't get that you got to go to this
restaurant it's a bit you just
oh yeah i was like dude i don't i don't
have 800 dispensable
hollywood too man it's jewish man he's
jewish also which also helps
jewish princess yes that's judaism
but it helps to be doctor drew man yeah
[ __ ] yes i have no awareness that [ __ ]
that's weird to me
and i think it's because because i look
at people that are very aware of that
stuff and i just think
i don't think you ever had a job right
like if you really worked in the world
for years like i did decades or killing
myself
that's that's your self-concept is the
guy grinding it out in the hospital
that's right that's it i'm still that
guy yeah and i think also since you
provide us like actually a like
documented service to people like a
diploma based service
then people give that a little bit of
different credit than a couple of
f-tards you know
i don't know they they like to knock
that down like me and brendan
and mike and nick yeah they like to
especially these days yeah for an asian
gym
really blue chin really really come in
pretty low
um well well dude you know 66 percent of
men start to lose their hair by 35 bro
now is this all men white latino black
everything urban
yeah here's wow does not discriminate
brother oh
we don't have a problem you got to set
it here i got to set it here but i'm
throwing my hair back out dude
and is it are you taking better care of
it this time i'm using hymns
yeah trying to get that bad boy you know
long get them dreads well look the thing
is i noticed in 2b about hymns is that
um it definitely it's almost like as if
you're a farmer or someone that owns
plants
and you want to take care of them if you
just put a plant outside who knows what
happens you got to fertilize it yeah
yeah you got to fertilize you got to
take care of it you got to farm it yeah
this is real stuff prescription
solutions backed by science no more
awkward in person
doctor visits and this ain't snake oil
nah man for him to connect you to
licensed medical professionals
online all right lmps baby licensed
medical professionals
and today right now hems is giving our
our
clientele uh a gift brother
yeah a big gift man and if you're not
happy with the results after 90 days
hymns will give you a full
refund so listen up cats all right go to
forehands.com
k-a-t-s that's for hims.com k-a-t-s
yep for a full refund of price paid
available for first 90 days supply
refund requests must be made between 90
and
180 days after product shipment
delivered
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for details
and important safety information
remember that's for hems.com
k-a-t-s and take care of your crop you
want to tighten up
hello fresh oh dang boy you freaking
flirting yeah
i'm flirting because i'm trying to make
you dinner poppy yeah
dog with a hello fresh it offers
convenient delivery right to your
doorstep for easy home cooking
with the fam with your bro and it's a
money saver yeah dude is it ever it's
delicious man gourmet recipes all right
it's a money saver you know do you know
this and i know you didn't so i'm going
to say it that you can save
40 oh wow off of your regular grocery
pricing
by using hellofresh unbelievable man
there's something for everyone
including low calorie if you're thick
like me vegetarian kid friendly recipes
we got it
all man it's flexible what do you need
we got you
give them that deal bro give them the
freaking deal
with that daisy what i'm telling you
right now is go to
hellofresh.com slash eight
zero the number eight the number zero k
a t s
and use code eight zero k ats to get a
total of eighty dollars off your first
month including free shipping on your
first box
additional restrictions apply visit
hellofresh.com for more details look i'm
telling you right now go to
hellofresh.com80kats
and use code80kats the meals they have
man
it comes with the meat it comes with the
chives it comes with the onion the
tomatoes baby
everything's in there the sauce the
packets the valuables the edible values
it's delicious damn it's in a box hello
fresh
go to hellofresh.com 80 cats k-a-t-s
and use the code 80 cats to get a total
of eighty dollars off your first
month including free shipping on your
first box additional restrictions supply
please visit hellofresh.com for more
details
cats and it sounds like a 101 dalmatians
have you seen that yes
this is the remakes we have robert
pattinson right here
uh from an outtake of their film
obviously hey robert
hey brendan hey theo matthew coming at
you from montreal canada
here for some sex advice oh here we go
so lately in the last three years i've
hadn't had sex once
and i'm finding it a little bit
concerning
maybe a little honorable but honor i'm
just
i've hit a rough patch lately i'm just
i'm working all the time
i'm a plumber full time so it's it
doesn't really go well
with the whole schedule of just going
out and meeting new people but i'd like
to know your thoughts on this
um gang gang buzz buzz
um one part of this on a playground
one part of it yeah it's kind of scary
you guys obviously donated most of his
blood too
yeah there's millions but he's really
handsome to not be [ __ ] for three
years yeah he's not a bad
dude which immediately makes me think is
he at us just to get laid
because it's just this guy's actually
really active and he just figured oh
this is another way to get laid with
with uh
you know well yeah sneak outside of
somewhere to make them
go to a playground is it a playground
yeah there's a playground behind them
in one of the dopest cities ever
montreal is the dopest place like
i would not be on a playground i'd be at
some poutine bar getting [ __ ]
hot montreal puntang jerk off out of a
window in montreal it'll land on
somebody
somewhere insanely hot here's the deal
he's got he's got to re-prioritize right
first of all you know how old he is i'm
assuming he's an adult right yeah
sometimes you know 15 year olds look
like very
he's a plumber though yeah he's that's
what i'm saying he's a plumber full time
the plumbers are beautiful this guy's
one of the best party speaks two
languages
i forgot to say get it reprioritize set
sometime aside it's that simple but make
it i mean it's got in these
days when you have absolutely there's a
million apps dude but it sounds like he
said he almost felt like uh
happy or not pro or proud of it
honorable so maybe there's some like
thing going on like a religious thing
yeah like he feels like he should be
like he's an incel or something or you
know that he has some issues around
maintaining abstinence but bottom line
is balance is important
balance your life not don't not just the
workaholism
put time aside to socialize he'll be
fine and i'm assuming he's a plumber
that's a monday through friday gig
saturday and sunday with the apps too
yeah but you could see how if somebody
really wanted to succeed they could they
could be plumbing 16 hours a week that's
what i
used to tell that to drew's son he has
triplets and two of them are boys
and they of course like any young 20 you
know in their early 20s they're
concerned about [ __ ]
and i would talk to them about i was
like dude honestly
if your 20s through like your 20s and
early 30s suck
that's probably a good thing it's the
guys i worry about are
constantly clubbing well past college
age they're not setting up their life
you
i said really make sure that these years
suck
because when you're 40 life's gonna be
[ __ ] awesome yeah and you're gonna
have money
and and a sense of self and you're gonna
be confident and you're just gonna be
they'll be
[ __ ] falling off of walls and hitting
you you could do both though right i
think there's a balance there to drew's
point i think you could do both
yeah you set your life up there's a
still they need a visit from uncle mike
we need a little
little chat that sounded gross kiddos
this cover thing has been rough on that
late 20s oh yeah
really do anything a lot of people are a
youtuber throwing parties they can't go
anywhere
jerking off a lot of men pretending gay
you know doing everything like that
you should write children's books for
adults mike that would be
nothing creepy about that well we need
them though i feel like i think you're
right
um yeah because i noticed if i jerk off
man i still feel pretty bad about it man
i feel guilty oh
shamed i jerked off yesterday i'll be
really honest with you not before you
ejaculate i was watching my arms too
actually just
i know when you jack up you're different
in here yeah you know it's just after
you get up
for ladies out there they may not
understand this phenomenon men
feel no shame no guilt until immediately
after the flesh oh i'll look at
the porno i was watching i'm like you're
disgusting after
after i cannot before you ejaculate
after i cannot relate i'm i'm con
i'm i'm already timing like when's the
next time i can beat off again
like i don't i do not feels disgusting
i have a really high confused and
confused and i feel like
for me beating off is more of like
marriage counseling
so limit to that point do you need to
like you your wife is like
that's his that's the pace she can
maintain and that's that yes you've got
to take care of yourself
and i'd much instead of like i like to
unload the chamber before i even go on
instagram before i even do anything
because then there's just less of a
chance of me
smart going astray so what what's the
rhythm
for the for the catheter family now i
would say
two or three nights a week okay so it's
pretty good rhythm it's a pretty good
rhythm
i'd say that's a lot right two or three
well hold on you've been together for
how long
average is one and a half and two to
three you're doing good one two three
nights a week there's the
there's the opportunity where we'll put
our daughter to bed and it's like you
know 8 30. but you're tired and
exactly and it's always it's always a
crap shoot where it's like i'll present
the idea
to my wife and and fifty percent of the
time she goes yeah honey let's do
and then another fifty percent of the
time she goes i'm super tired and i get
it i'm always never the other way
where she's where she's yeah sometimes
with me it's the other way no there's
never happened
but you grind harder than most people
and i also i'm also
[ __ ] gross like i mean i will admit
it i i
i'll be i'll hi i've done this i've beat
off in the bathroom done that
walked into my bedroom and my wife's
like can we have sex and i'm like yes we
can oh god bless you
you know you are you're a superhero
because my dick is hurt
it's the only way i can captain america
on a contra team or something
what's the only way i can be somewhat
successful
it's the only way i can be somewhat
successful because i pretty much
ejaculate so much so i'm
lucky my gift is that i can do it over
and over again but i come in like
25 seconds that's a gift though it's a
gift
it's a gift relax dude and how much is
that you guys have been together
a handful uh we've been married seven
years we've been together probably like
a little under nine
then we have a kid different animal yeah
yeah so
you know i've been through the i've run
the cycle right so
we're together since 84 we've got
married 91
we're still three times a week yeah
oh my god you got to get drew's wife on
this show she's the best
three times a week and yeah well that's
after she got the prosthetic limbs
because drew had already [ __ ] smashed
her in half with his
gigantic hebrew hog yeah that's what
gigantic documented
kosher log that he goes in there i've
seen i'll go to visit and or we'll go
out to dinner and
susan just comes in walking like she's
been horrified sometimes we'll sometimes
pick up beyond that pace
it's pretty good that's all still is the
butt is the butt open for business is
the butt open for business in the
peninsula
oh bro there's a friend of students you
can't stand it
relax i don't know her so finish this
i think i want too many email changes
whether they even know it and
and i mean this and i'm not even being
gross susan if for a woman her age is
like a ten yeah he's like
honestly very beautiful very that's
that's why i wouldn't expect nothing
left that should be what
women aspire to look like at that age
three times a week
can we edit that out nick i don't need
this sort of harassment from my wife
now why has it changed i feel like it's
changed over time a lot of men
you know don't want to have sex as much
and women want to have sex
more do you think it's like the media
that makes us think that
a lot of biological changes across a
lifespan right and so you gotta
you gotta pay attention to everybody's
biology and if you don't work to
maintain it like
women after menopause things just die
and that needn't be
you can do hormone replacement i do i'm
doing a lot of podcasting about the
pellets and things like that to help
women
really enjoy their life more i mean they
are miserable when they are menopausal
and they are
so much better men too testosterone
replacement men too it's a little you
know it's a little lower level
replacement kind of thing and but in
extreme cases a guy i've i've known
men um particularly head trauma patients
oh
well i i talked to a personal friend of
mine who was a marine and he served
uh overseas and he he had serious trauma
and his hormone levels because of that
yeah i'm not talking low they were
non-existent
yeah literally he had no testosterone
that's where depression oh yeah
he started doing the trt and it
literally saved his life yeah it's not
hyperbole
people have to be yeah people have to
pay attention you should because a lot a
lot of
what goes down as depression in the 50s
and 60s in women is actually just
menopausal syndrome
or perimenopause in their 30s and 40s
the point is
you can keep things really going so and
i've always said that you know whatever
that thing is that's there at the
beginning with your wife if you can keep
that
every day if every day that's still
there that's a successful marriage
yeah dude yeah but it's but you don't
have to you have to worry about 10 years
down the line
if tomorrow is the same as today one
step at a time but when you were
chew when you were not choosing your
right when you guys chose each other
were you able to notice some of those
things in advance because i feel like
you meet a girl and you're like
who knows what's in here yeah yeah no
it's a leap of faith let's be fair
but dude but i had a stranger i had a
strange reaction to her where i met her
twice
and i'm really shy i can't go out people
and i didn't know it was the same person
and i i had to talk to her both times oh
wow and gave her my number both times
which i've never done
like ever wow yeah and she was like and
i didn't learn it was her
this the sec until we'd been dating a
year and i saw a picture of the night
where i met her the first time i was
like oh you were there that night oh my
god that was you that's cool
yeah she's like i'm dating this guy with
autism
theo like honestly taking that leap of
faith like
yes and no i think a lot of guys myself
included i did this
for a long time you feel like you're
doing something wrong by factoring in
a woman's sex drive into whether or not
you want to settle down with her oh no
that's got to fit together you got like
don't it's not a leap of faith as much
as you try different women and if a
woman's not as sexually active as you
are or is sexually interested
like she's not a good fit you're not
being a dick by doing that
it's just serious isn't everything
though it's not everything but i
i would like to say a factor that should
be you shouldn't dismiss it as a
non-factor
i like to say it's like hair and nails
it's not cancer
but if your hair and nails are failing
like there's something up there's
something up in internally here
tonight what's this is this this just a
text question here uh yeah we had some
other ones but i
i wanted to try to help uh some people
there were a couple reasons
some people is this from nick hey guys
seaman instead of [ __ ] please
yes hey guys i was curious what causes
some guys to
see me ejaculate like a firehouse and
some
ejaculate faucet okay i've got some
little junk
but i can throw ropes across the room
this this felt very love-lining
yeah it is very lovely so people are all
i hear even joe rogan making this
mistake the other day he
he was people confuse where the
ejaculate fluid comes from
it has nothing to do with your testes
wow nothing that's new except except the
testosterone production
that the testes create sperm and
testosterone
sperm cells the fluid is created by your
prostate gland
wow and it is stored in the seminal
vesicles which are these
sort of looks like a wing almost under
the prostate of these these chambers
that store the fluid
and some people can produce a lot of
fluid and store a lot of fluid and
like mike can reproduce it very quickly
and they can put out
and big volumes and that's just a
genetic thing that just some people are
that way
wow uh and so there's nothing you do to
enhance your
no that's well you can you could refrain
from
ejaculate does that help i heard it
helps use it or lose it oh at that point
it helps it helps to a point yeah it
helps to a point but you can also go the
other way but
people like me that don't have a
prostate which produces the fluid
mike those loads no fluids ghost loads
there's nothing
it's just like magic one of those
hairless cats one of those hairless cats
but does it feel the same same same
weird
sounds like a tom clancy novel i don't
like it i don't like harry potter
i need i need that i need that enzo
celebration you know
like i need to [ __ ] yeah yeah i want
to i want to end zone dance yeah just
like a windy day and that's
it uh there's even no wind it's just
normal is there a noise is it just
i make the noise but that's it oh my god
but does anybody believe you if no semen
comes out does anybody believe yeah
you could fake it all the time you you
you first of all i don't think males are
motivated to fake you know what i mean
oh i know i've been there really
anything to get me out of the damn
bedroom dude i would do it
there's a lot packed into that statement
i feel like you guys might need a one on
one
but anyway so the point is the prostate
and the several vesicles where all the
fluid comes from
and into the seminal vesicles the the um
sperm just drips into the fluid to put
more sperm concentrations
oh wow like that budweiser plant like
you've ever been there
golden uh golden color of course yeah so
the the testes are just producing
cells of swimmers that make their way up
the vas deferens and drip into the
mix now what about korean people and
people other people do they have the
same thing everybody has it the same do
some people have a thick
more you know dilute badge yes
as this questioner was asking there's a
whole range of volume
fluid you know thickness and there's
tapioca pudding there's all kinds of
stuff
well this is like an episode of catch a
predator look here's the thing man these
days it's all about the look man
it's all about the clout man and i know
if anybody let me see that watch bruh
what's up bro
damn bro and i know where you got that
at blue nile baby
bluenile.com you can celebrate all of
life's special moments
from creating the custom engagement ring
of her dreams to gifting a
once-in-a-lifetime piece
at prices you won't find at a
traditional jeweler dude nothing says i
love you like that
hot diamond put that warm [ __ ] right on
her finger you know what i'm saying or
if you love a man get him that diamond
oh get on that diamond stud aaron
whatever you
need man vintage classic modern the
possibilities are endless
why add more stress to your jewelry
shopping one stop shop
talking about that blue nile for
engagement to anniversaries and
birthdays you need to have a trusted no
pressure jewelry to help you celebrate
the the unique thing brendan is that
they
you call them and they they they have a
trusted person on the line they'll go
over with you how to build it it's like
your little helper
it is diamond helper it's like sending
somebody into the mine with the pickaxe
and letting them know what you want
if you want to get tiger get them a
little uh diamond crusted backpack
or you want to get bossed in a little uh
pacifier with that big uh ruby on these
okay so celebrate your love and life
special moments
with jewelry from bluenow.com and king
of sting listeners you get 50
off your first purchase of over 750
dollars
this is exclusive it includes loose
diamonds use code k-a-t-s that's code
k-a-t-s
plus every order is insured ships free
and arrives in discreet packaging
that won't give away what's inside oh
good shop stress free
and find your forever piece go to
bluenile.com
today what are these guys seriously i'm
not i'm not okay with this already
bebop and [ __ ] steady straight from
4chan
pick right or left these guys are not
related at all
i want i want guido on the left first i
gotta talk to that guy
how old do you guys think this guy is
i'm 24 in my i
rock and uh he might be 37. you guys 19.
he's obviously a cat's fan so what's
going on boys i got a question from mike
and dr drew
i'm 20 years old and i would rather hook
up with a 45 year old woman with a
motley crew
tattoo on her lower back than a girl my
age
is that normal gang gang buzz buzz mom
issues am i right
well what's weird to me is that there's
a lot of that these days
and i don't know if it's a function of
older women or
you know women in their 45th and 60s are
out of the sexual revolution they sort
of
maybe are more sexually kind of out
there
because we went through all that you
know what i mean well it seems like now
there's kind of a different movement
where everybody's me too well yeah
though that's a thing dude if i'm a 20
year old now
okay i look at a 45 year old woman who's
like
yeah i want to [ __ ] i find let's do this
when i'm surrounded by 20 20 year old
girls who everything seems very rigid
and i'm kind of scary i would be very
scared
of 20 year olds are scared yeah
no males the males are scared the males
are i don't want anything wrong i don't
be seen as a rapist
they're very scared they don't know
quite what the parameters are
so even with that fear dr drew is it
able for are they able to still
but you can't eliminate your sexual
desires is that possible like i know
there's like
maybe this different mind frame like
okay i'm scared i don't know if it's
okay to be sexual that sort of thing
so but are you able to physically and
like whatever it is biologically
decrease the same desire that we felt as
kids
so so in other words you're trying to
take their perspective like
when i was 20 i did not find 45 year
olds attractive
but 45 year olds were different when we
were 20. you know what i mean it's a
different
population so they look i think they're
more attractive now they look like well
45 year olds
are better when you were 20 45 year olds
were dead i know you know because it was
[ __ ] the cowboy era that's right or
they were been smoking for 30 years or
whatever grapes of wrath
yeah it's sexy um and so so your
question really is why are they so
attracted to the older
older women and maybe that's porn
there's a lot of sort of wait but also
wait a second
i think you're getting going to more of
a base level theo was onto something
later like
i think that a lot of this is
speculation i think a lot of
young men associate because of this push
of
matriarchal statehood this idea that
everything that is masculinity
is toxic masculinity somehow they get
imposed with this idea that
i'm really horny and i love [ __ ]
therefore i'm doing something wrong yes
and and of course what really is doing
something wrong is how you act on and
how you behave on it and
being a ledge is is wrong and and and
and forcing yourself on a woman is wrong
but
embracing the fact that you're a horny
young man isn't
and and it's probably for the 20 year
old brain a really difficult it's a
scary
to un to unfold that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm asking i think not even
to do with the 45 year olds but say
you're
you're 20 years old right now and when i
was 20 you had so much
sexual energy you know and you wanted to
do sex right
but what if but now your brain and the
society is telling you it's wrong if you
pee the
wrong way you're a [ __ ] rapist you
know what i'm saying like anything if
you look at your dick while you pee
you're going
to hell some woman's going to kidnap you
in a [ __ ] dodge caravan all this [ __ ]
right everybody's in fear
yeah but does that fear still stop does
it stop
the does it actually curtail the
biological desire i don't think so
i don't think so i think the way you do
that is you scare kids
and sometimes that can do that right but
it does the fear
once you've already you already your
biology is already set
it just sort of puts a cap on it and
makes them confusing see that's crazy
because then where does that go right
now it goes bad there's always there's
always a tremendous problem that comes
from the dissonance between what you're
told and what you're feeling
but remember the real problem with that
we don't know it's like a more full
effect
of porn yeah too i mean they a lot of
the males are sort of like
good with them they like i have found
back where you're doing a love line a
lot of guys are like uh
i'd like a girlfriend but they're
they're a lot of work i'm okay i got
born you know there's a little porn he
really kind of takes the edge off a
little bit for some of these kids i
don't know we don't
get affected that yet i don't though
i'll tell you the full effect it's not
good
yes for me it has not been i know it's
like because i feel like these haunting
images in my head i think
and it just keeps me from like uh
hunting images as far as the porn you
watch
yeah like it's fun with a girl no just
overall the images are fine in the
videos it's fine it is what it is
i don't think anybody's wrong for doing
it but i just think that then it affects
the way that i
could behave or think in a sexual way
because you're being influenced by the
porn you watch right that's the thing
you're expecting the girl to be like the
girls you're watching or
yeah or just you or just you don't think
of people
like you don't think like there's
somebody they do porn somewhere in this
building
you know sure i don't know where it is
but uh let me know because i've been
let's go
let's go let's go take
nick knows and he's almost he's been
suspended once let's just say that
just came back from suspension uh but
now i saw the other day i saw a girl
walking into one of the offices right
and she had like a bag and she's got
different costumes kind of thing
and i'm like okay this is but but also i
noticed with this girl just by my glance
this all judgment okay here's a young
lady she's tired she looks like she's
had a tough week or something
like just all the stuff you don't take
into account when it comes to porn like
porn you just see this finished product
yeah
your your i think if i would distill it
down what you're saying is you're
fearful you will treat people like
objects not human beings
but we do that with everything i think
if it's fair to do it with just porn we
do that with our athletes too
right you look at them comment you're
millionaires just playing i've noticed
i'll tell you what we really have
opinions on really this gentleman the
corolla and i have been talking about
this lately
yeah which is that what what has really
happened
is we're treat we treat people like
cartoon characters
like everyone in media has become a
cartoon that you're entitled to act out
on
cancer cancer they don't really exist
they're just cartoons
and and it's really i think i think tv
started it like in the 60s with
gilligan's island yeah and it's become
like pervasive now i think there's a
social media
and reality because it's a reality team
it's all everyone's a cartoon
yeah but i think so even yes everybody's
a cartoon everyone's
and so it's like these aren't humans and
i think it's the same thing with
pornography i think that's what you're
getting onto
and it's causing us to behave in really
obnoxious ways
to humans who just happen to be in the
public sphere really also look at yeah
also i also like we should take into
consideration
that even prior to lockdown
which has only made things worse most
people
work way more hours than ever before and
are making less money than ever before
in comparison to how much everything
costs
every when i was growing up i'm not you
know you you were
in the same age bracket when we were
growing up even regular people
there was usually a one income household
and you you were able to do it you had a
couple cars you go on vacation and my
friend's death were cops or teachers and
like
they you could live the life it's not
[ __ ] the way it is anymore everyone's
overworked overstressed
underpaid and then you see people on tv
and on the internet who are rich
and seemingly not doing anything harder
than what you're doing
you're just like [ __ ] because you're
comparing yourself to them because now
if i'm you know a regular dude or a
regular let's say i'm a 18 year old girl
and get on instagram i see kylie jenner
and her
wagon and her gucci purses now you know
or when i was a kid and i got a cool car
at 16
but then i see travis scott with his g
wagon now instead of comparing my car to
the kid who was up the street
i'm you're compared to the world now
right and that's people have this
resentment and we all rose lead to
narcissism we're all
we're all kind of narcissistic these
days everybody yep some more than others
but if you really have a good dose of it
like it's from childhood trauma and
stuff
you're gonna express envy and envy is
extremely destructive emotion so you're
going to feel
she pisses me off she's got what i got
to bring her down to me i'm going to
bring her down to my
social media to help that that's the
canceling that's the mob that's
everything and that's what we're into
these days and it's
really destructive it's it's again i
cannot warn people enough
that is a horrible instinct to be
jealous and envious
and knock people down that is the worst
that human beings have to offer
crab mentality but how do we how how is
there a way to curtail like like should
only certain like should you have to
finish high school or do so like what
should you have to do to get a social
media like
you know it almost seems like you get a
driver's license right which allows you
to act and behave with a vehicle
and but a social media account these
days is a vehicle it's like
you have people some anybody can be a
real person
to have your real name on there say
something on twitter and they'll cite it
on cnn or on
and could be life altering to the person
they're talking about like like
destroying
i put the i think a lot of people look
at it as like what can we do to get the
public to start doing this
i honestly think like maybe the
responsibility falls within people in
front in the public eye
maybe there needs to be a little bit
more transparency in the fact that like
i think you're taught regardless of what
level of athlete athletics politics or
or um entertainment when you get into
the public eye
you kind of create this idea it's this
unspoken rule that you pretend like it
doesn't affect you
just keep on trucking keep on trucking i
think the more and more
we expose the fact that athletes
politicians and entertainers are
actually human beings that have moms and
dads and daughters and sisters and
brothers
and we're like no you know that really
makes me feel horrible
and um i've been suicidal and i feel
fill in the blank
because i'm a human being just like you
i happen to be in movies or i happen to
play football for a living but i'm a
[ __ ] human being with feelings
and uh maybe i'm not saying you should
but maybe we should all
right you know why because bullying face
to face
has a way of working out all kids are
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] little kids
are [ __ ]
all the way up through even teenage
years but what happens is
most people unless they're sociopaths
you act like an [ __ ]
and every once in a while you see how
your behavior affects another person you
see
you look at it like oh man i really
[ __ ] hurt that guy's feelings when i
made fun of him in front of everybody or
in front of the football team and if
somebody whoops you for being an [ __ ]
and i
and then or yes someone humbles you
reality has a way
of filtering out not only genetic things
but actually social things too
there's a filter where you go and you
grow and that's what creates evolution
the internet divorces and maturity and
selfhood and adulthood
and the internet divorces you from that
so i think maybe if if we in the public
eye
even real select you know all the way up
to a-list people like me on the z-list
all the way up to the a-list
start to say like um you're right you're
entitled to your opinion you're entitled
to your twitter account
but uh you don't know me and you just
[ __ ] on me and i that really hurt my
feelings you know it does suck
i don't think that would stop it i don't
even maybe not maybe maybe not it might
be
smart though my fear is also that
television is so
cartoonizing of people that they won't
stop they won't stop just continuing the
cartoon images
and then people feeling justified in
acting out this is the every time i
i've had conversation with 27 year olds
do i go look you cancel people and they
can't make a living
he goes at least there i've had a guy go
at least they're alive i go oh
whoa man if you've been working on
something for 50 40 years it's your
career it's your identity
and the now there's no possibility of
moving forward yeah so what
so what this is what's going on right
now it's like
oh my god you're destroying you they
haven't understood
that's something inside him why he's
unhappy it's real
pleasure off them losing their goods but
do they have that thing inside of us i
just wonder if the mainframe
of feeling and of understanding
that is in a lot of people from our
generation if it's in these
if it's not now in the hand and not
in the i i think the compassion's there
i think what do you mean compassion's
there
just like you know like you would say
like we we would see something we would
feel bad this would happen you would
in the world yes and now it's just like
i just wonder i start to wonder if the
same set of values or understanding
or empathy exists in younger people that
it did
this is getting in the way of developing
that right
but but that's my point though if you
took that away and did it in a more
real-life fashion here here's an example
why do i agree that gentlemen i believe
his name is daryl i wish i could
remember his full name but yeah
he work at a um it's not that
daryl what does he look like red hair uh
no no he's a black gentleman
uh he doesn't work at that uh
you work to the jiffy lube on ventura
boulevard no no i'm talking about okay
this guy
he i believe he's on rogan and he he
goes around
hammond talking to klansmen oh yeah and
he's a black guy and he uh he just
spends time with him he just steals
their
i'm not trying to change you i just want
to spend time with you and through
spending time with them they change they
he collects their [ __ ] hoods and he
comes and these guys all come on they're
like i don't know what i was thinking
you know why because that's reality
there's empathy
and seeing someone and talking to
someone and experience someone you
literally don't do that it's a weird
facsimile of doing it when you look at
your phone or you look at your computer
screen
but it is not the same and until people
can realize that like
through human interaction it's the only
way moral and ethical things can be put
in place
laffy taffy ursula right there you're a
boy let me just say though there was a
famous
book in the 50s a guy went out and tried
to study how to deal with
uh discrimination and bias and stuff and
the book was called
contact that contact with
with another person that's different
than you is what takes away
all that [ __ ] yeah and it's also but
and one thing we don't see in the media
there's not the they never the truth the
full story isn't there
it's like you have a cartoon story
always the cartoon clickbait
it's just the same and it's also like
you know like and i think we have to
start looking at things not at like
i feel like it would be better if we
looked at things as a
as a people problem than as a like i
constantly feel like racism is always
blamed on white people you know
and i see a ton of racism that goes from
all different ethnicities and we talk
about it on here sometimes that there's
racism
across all walks and towards each other
that's our brain has a glitch and that
and racism is one of the glitches we
have to pay attention to so we don't
fall victim to it
now drew are you do you do any drugs or
anything like that
right now not today or but overall or
you are
not many many many many years really
now marijuana or anything that's illegal
drugs no i i keep thinking i
it scares me oh look um
she's a friend yeah she's amazing she's
comedian comedian yeah that's vicky
gumbel's yeah no no no it's um what's
her name oh he may just looks like her
oh no she's not comedian okay she's
she's chin's axe and he screwed her over
not my ex we set you up
with chender a while back on a date with
this beautiful young lady
so but she's uh you know just like the
rest of us during quarantine and
just in life you know love can be kind
of uh you know
something we all tricky yeah capricious
uh nick you want to bring her in here
chan you want to bring her in actually
chen
very pretty girl yeah this is uh my my
first ever
chinder date card congratulations
[Applause]
what's up carly you know not much
okay well look carly uh you guys want to
take us
uh everybody needs a little bit of uh
luck and love and
and can also use some suggestions and
guidance sometime that's
a little direction a little direction so
that's why we have here uh dr drew and
mike
um i just want to know what's going on
with your love life and if you have any
questions you could use some answers for
some suggestion uh
[Music]
um life is
pretty much the same dating nothing like
crazy serious
and i don't know that's kind of like
about about it
how old are you you don't mind me asking
i'm just
just turned 26 two weeks ago all right
you're right in the thick of it this is
my
personal opinion i'm a guy i can't put
myself in your shoes but this is from
what i've seen
and i'm only talking through my
experience
wait till you're about 32 to start
realistically thinking about finding a
lifelong part smart
because not to their own fault men in
their
20s mid-20s animals until the advanced
guy can be like
27 like drew sons they're they're pretty
square away guy like me
i was like 32 33 before i even had the
ability
to invest real um sympathy and interest
into
a female what if she dated older guys
they should get guys in their early 30s
yeah yeah you're at that age where i
think it's not gross the point is
men or animals until they're about 27.
they should we should be like we should
have been caged
we're super super here should've been
just caged and put in a cage and
we are she literally was put in the cage
all of a sudden i was engaged
yeah all of we're all going to be in a
half of our friends are in cages we're
going to be in a zoo soon
okay you're just really insecure right
you don't have a lot going on for
yourself most of the time most guys
most guys are 25 26 they're just they're
trying to put their life together
they're working they're
typically really invested in their
career building themselves and then they
don't even get that
kind of free um that that that that
processing power to think about like oh
my god this is a human being
and i gotta really listen to her when
she has problems and i gotta invest my
time into
what's going on in her life and it's
there and they're also
pumping testosterone through their body
so they're [ __ ] horny monkeys
it's a really bad combo yeah and
and but the other thing is that men for
whatever reason males seem to
need a sense of their identity in the
world before they can understand who
they are and then be available for
another person yeah right yeah yeah
but but she can have fun you're saying
before she gets serious no do your thing
do your thing
right yeah you're you're a living
breathing human being that has needs and
desires go have fun do your thing
i'm saying don't get serious don't or
or find yourself a guy who's 33 and
really to treat you like you're a
princess so that was our 12-minute
diatribe of her telling us how old she
is
she didn't ask us any questions she's
not she was like king or sting it
uh real housewives of orange county
jesus christ now
uh when it comes to these relationships
or this dating do you try to make
yourself a little more available and do
you find that a lot of guys are
like based on what mike and drew were
saying are you finding that to be kind
of true or
what do you think i think it can go both
ways i mean there's
so i'm 26 i usually tend to date older
because
growing up you're always told like men
have
what are like two years younger in
maturity level yeah
more likely maybe more yeah maybe 10.
but i think yeah i mean
my track record is a lot of jerks
so and then i think like the few ones
that were nice it was just like timing
didn't work out well
uh-oh so do you have a broken picker
we gotta kiss some frogs well that's
true but maybe
maybe her picker's off she's sort of
attracted to the a-holes yeah you got
this drew
yeah i think my figure is definitely off
yeah do you
like the bad boys
yeah kind of but i also think that
i was listening to something and it was
about like you know i think
maybe the same with men too but just
that the challenge or like the chase or
the
yeah like the bad boy douchey kinds like
i don't know why but somehow their
women find them more interesting or
maybe not always it's usually
primal it's it's younger women and most
women
outgrow that by around 22 23 so you need
to outgrow this
it is not you are not going to change
them it is not going to go well
yeah i can definitely say i'm i'm pretty
over that i will say like
uh there was a period of time like i
think also it just gains
a lot of it comes with like maturity and
dating right
looking back like obviously at college
that's not dating um
and then even after college just still
not
really being mature in dating and then
now it's been a couple years and i'm 26
and um i think just even looking at the
last two years like
you kind of have to like grow within
yourself and like
i know for me like and so how did the
chinder date figure into this
well well chin and her shared a bunch of
sake
and then at the end of the day was like
actually i'm married
yeah that's how that went it was so
funny because they tried to
do this segment called chinder and i was
single at the time and then right when
we found
carl that right around that time is when
i started dating my
my best friend and chin didn't tell us
this or i couldn't i don't want to ruin
it for everyone so i was like ah it's
already too late we already did this
committed committed to the to the
product i get that yeah she was awesome
now carly i have a question now these
men that you're spending time with are
these
when it comes to sexualness are you guys
ha
are they are these men you know real
confident or they erect or what's going
on there
what do you mean like are just are they
are they having like erectile problems
are you noticing anything like that with
some of these younger fellows
are they too aggressive maybe a little
bit that's yours
i'm trying to help you how's chin's
bulgogi that's what we're asking how's
the
no i just want to know if you're seeing
any sexual difficulties with these damn
young
the youngins with these youngsters yeah
no can't can't say no well
okay wow i like anything i'm saying
that i feel like especially with guys
like in my
age range and like i have friends i have
guy friends that are my best friends
so i know whatever they're doing well
those guys are stalking you just so you
know
i'm not kidding your best friends that
that are your men friends they're
waiting for their moment i've always
said that not that you can't not that
you can't be friends with men i'm not
saying that
i'm saying well okay i think it's i
think he overstated by saying they're
stalking you here's what the true
true reality here's the reality you're
very you're very attractive girl you
seeming you're
seemingly very nice you have a good
energy about you they may not be
actively stalking you but at any given
point
even though they're your friends they
want it at any given point if you're
like
we should just [ __ ] they'd be like yeah
yeah you're right you're totally right
and i'm going to do this right guys
these guys used to call us on love line
all the time
her friends well the equivalent
of this we heard this all the time and
they would go like you know
did you let let me ask you this did you
at one time your best friends
did you at one time have a date with at
the beginning of the relationship or a
couple of dates
no so you never dated these guys ever
okay well that's good like a lot of my
best guy friends like or
ones that are single i should say yeah
um they are just strictly friends
has there been the encounter that you're
talking about where your friend yeah
they'd want to date me yes but we're not
friendly right
mike on this at any given point those
boys want in the game well there's
opportunity
the ones you got to watch over the ones
that that you dated and then he settles
for friend
that guy's talking oh that guy's talking
classic stuff
and are y'all doing drugs too what's
that
that that doesn't really work because
yeah he's a doctor though you know
and then you want to be friends you're
going to hook up again like that's a
dead giveaway
but then are you friends though
you know what i'm saying i don't [ __ ]
yeah you know i've never [ __ ] you down
that i'm being friends well i'm friends
with somebody i'm not [ __ ] yeah my
best friend let me [ __ ] other people you
feel me
mike there was at one time yes we
weren't supposed to talk about that on
the air
but i wrecked his [ __ ] but i'm glad
to know that you are still enjoying
some good times during the disease you
know yeah that is good yeah
it's important to know that people are
out there in case the world ends that
people are still doing sex and people
are still doing stuff
yeah i agree you know what i really
appreciate chin keeping it real like a
korean man pour my drink
you pour my drink dude mike knows the
culture that's right
i i was blown away i had two korean
girlfriends and i
that always blew my [ __ ] mind because
the women have to pour the drink poor
poor might the soju i would
be barely finished boom poor drink open
the door for me and it's like
and it's not not anymore brother have
you gone on if you go on a date with the
korean in 2020 it's the woke culture
is that true has it been ruined i
haven't dated a korean girl for a long
time
so one of the symptoms in my life that i
know i'm miserable and covet and really
it's a symptom of how
how far i've sunk is i become excite
obsessed with the 90-day fiance reality
and that's a sick symptom oh yeah but
as a result of many many hours of
viewing of that
hazara is that what you do yeah yeah
um i uh i've learned about other
cultures and this male female stuff
that's crazy
how about the african guy oh my god and
his culture though yeah hold on you need
to bow down to the man
you have to take care of what they call
it submissive yeah and she's not
speaking
and she goes i'm american it ain't
happening i'm telling you right now it
ain't going to go down
they casted that perfectly this is the
best hey i want to i want to point out
your boy soldier boy is it a new season
no you're gonna we'll sit down and watch
it with you sometimes it's so good to do
a viewing party yeah because we have our
own pillow talks
yeah yeah yeah we come over there and do
it
that's a great idea come on man i'll
watch a couple episodes i love it yeah
and like
because she's like traditional south and
she's like very like
women and then he's you straight from
like kenya or nigeria
i forget where nigeria nigerian yeah and
there it's like the woman
who stays at home takes care of the man
oh yeah yeah food you know
all the elders in the family the females
are like well of course you'll submit to
him and she's like
i'll do what she's like this is over
she's like i'm a marriage she's a damn
dixie chick she sounds like one of the
darkest dixie kids they're just dicks
yeah they're not they're just dixie now
thank you so much for jumping in today
and you'll be great yeah
you'll be great you got it you're fine
yeah you're fine yeah you're really fine
but i'm with drew your best friends are
crazy well you just be careful that's
all just know
see look at their motivation that's and
i do think men and women can be great
friends that's not my thing at all
but sometimes harbor people harbor a
little desire behind that yeah you're
right i've
i've loved being married because of that
that has been a great female friend that
has been a great gift i have legitimate
female friends because my motives aren't
no really ranted yes oh yeah do they
look like warlocks no no no no like like
like katie ellis jason's
katie ellis is [ __ ] fine and if i was
single
it would be weird if i was her friend
now especially because jason's wife
like like it's well your buddy's wife
like dr drew's wife but even like my
wife's
my wife's friends who are oftentimes
actresses and [ __ ] and they're like
[ __ ] crazy hot like i love the
ability to differently i'm saying you
meet a girl at a coffee shop
i'm not making friends with her that's
what i'm saying too dangerous if it's
your buddy's girlfriend or
or wife then you can be friends with
them right but if it's just an outsider
and she's single yeah but even girls
like co-workers that are attractive
like now i feel really comfortable like
being like asking just talking having
conversations
engaging in that way because yeah i'm
not my motives aren't the same you know
like
i like that too as i i think some of
that's also just as i get a little bit
older i'm just able to recognize like
you don't have to try to be sexual
towards any woman who just kind of shows
you attention
or you don't all you know sometimes it's
just gonna be a bad idea
well it's like it's like cat you know
cat's probably my best one of my best
female friends she's a single
24 year old you know i i don't
look at i don't even it's almost like
she's this little sister
right but i will say this with younger
girls now though
um and and i mean obviously legally aged
humans i'm glad you said that you bet
yeah uh
but um i definitely get more
scared now of even talking to a girl
probably that's what imagine you're 27.
you know me you're 25 how how scared
you'd be
oh i can't even imagine so yeah
well hey good times i just don't want to
do any crime what's your favorite
episode of nine day fiance yeah
uh oh i like the one when uh humble he's
like russian or something
and they fly all the way from the
moldova to boldova
and they get there and the fiance and
the dude then the brother about the
fight not at one point
they're in there he goes we'll go
outside i'll show you because he has
like a sketchy pass
they're like why were you in dublin yeah
why are we in ireland
and he's like please just stop with the
questions they keep picking at him and
then finally he's like shut up
the first time you mean and i see the
evil hand of producers behind a lot of
it too they're just
pouring the alcohol yeah there's a lot
of alcohol and then they both stand up
they're about to straight up
fight it's fantastic i love that do you
think there should be any repercussions
to some of these production companies
that are just pouring gas and the people
that's
reality tv i understand that i
understand that
it's not though theo's onto something
you're looking at it from a seasoned
not only a professional athlete but a
guy who has grinded in the entertainment
industry and you've you've developed a
kind of
a maturity in it yes imagine if you're
from theo's hometown you're 19
20 you come to la and some [ __ ]
exploitive
disgusting producer comes and they're
like it's gonna be great go on the
bachelorette you're going to be awesome
and then they pour alcohol down and then
and you're having this
existential thing on set and they go
we're going to talk to you
you're totally right for hating that guy
right because and they've so
i've had that so watch this
watch the scripted series unreal because
that is the that is an
accurate portrayal of how it goes down
and if you still want to do it then it's
on they're adults it's on them yeah what
it
is
what's interesting because when i was
young we had um or when i was young
enough you know
to be 19 we had um
you they hadn't had reality television
out there yeah they only had a few years
of it sure
so it wasn't just road rules yeah road
rules in real world like that was it so
you would you could go into
reality tv as a contestant or as a cast
member
and be yourself still you weren't savvy
to the game
right now like nor were the producers
yes they weren't upping the
they weren't upping the game the same
way agreed it was different i remember a
lot of it is
casting a lot of how they cast
their dreams oh yeah at night we would
spend time playing somebody who had an
instrument
there were people there that were
doctors that were uh that are now
politicians that were just spending
their you know spending a two week or a
month period
taking out from their lives and at night
we'd sit around a campfire it was a
little different
and then it escalated to where it was
just there be no milk but there would be
tequila but even on ultimate fighter
it's like you know you have this
list every every night you give the list
the next morning the food would come
if we asked for you know burger meat or
chicken breast
it would come you know maybe by midday
if we asked for alcohol it would be
there that
night right so no no dummy so that is
that has been the the
outside piece is the part that i always
have been concerned about and
and i'm sorry what'd you say the alcohol
part is the part i've been concerned
about and to some extent i'm being a bit
facetious and saying that the producers
were forcing the alcohol
it was probably some local moldovian
film crew let's face it
provided and then it's provided and they
weren't really drinking that much
i think they backed off that i think i
think people understand that they that
that's
not cool but here's what i don't like
maybe in some of the mpv but here's what
i don't like about it there's an
inconsistency
and you and i both know this firsthand
because in one way they take reality
innocent reality tv stars
yeah i know they're delivering but
they're still they're still just normal
humans
and they put them in the in the pit of
fire and they push it a heightened
situation
they also at the same time television
producers
overly protect politicians and
established entertainers you know when
we would have to do an interview with
fill in the blank politician
or or a big celebrity there's like this
is exactly what you can and can
ask this is exactly what you can't topic
you can't even go into this
and uh make sure that there is this and
this on set or else we're not showing up
and so there's an inconsistency where
they're taking the average joe and the
average jane
and they're [ __ ] with them as much as
possible but yet overly protecting the
people that we
probably most need to get to the bottom
well like i have a buddy who did a thing
on a large network we all know and it
was a competition comedy thing
and he went out there and crushed it and
crushed it and gets back and they go
you know man with your childhood would
your uh dead
you know father and uh friend what would
are they here and he's like
what and like and then they keep prying
he's like oh this isn't about comedy at
all yeah you guys are trying to paint
this narrative it's a reality show and
he
he's not savvy to it at all and he's
like no i just crushed on stage i'm good
man i'm not thinking about my dad or my
dead friend i'm thinking about
beating in this competition he didn't
get selected because they're not going
to play the game they're not going to be
even though he's the best comic by far
there they didn't pick him because he
wouldn't play the game
i thought i think who ate [ __ ] but had
some childhood trauma and talked about
it
but the interesting thing i also know
i'm just finishing up the kind of the
point i was making i'm slow to get to
points because i don't know sometimes
what i'm
exactly going to talk about but i'm
saying this is that
um now people grow up watching enough
reality tv that when they
get to a show that they're on they
already
have a character that they're going to
be with it's almost like it's just
re it's it's so it's so bizarre cartoons
well
look at the real housewives give me the
real housewives man you watch the real
housewives and it's insane
i told you dawg [ __ ] vg though
back back to one of the earlier points
we're talking about is how people make
an assumption about a certain part of
the country
if you watch beverly hills housewives
you think that's how people are in
beverly hills if you watch the hills you
think that's how people are in l.a
you watch jersey shore you think that's
how dirt and it's like dude i lived in
jersey for two years
some of the most [ __ ] educated
thoughtful people and it's like
but they love to create this idea that
it's all guidos they love to create the
idea that everyone
in the south is this [ __ ] toothless
racist and it's like
dude what are we doing you gotta
remember that what that humans
the whole nature of drama i mean what
did sophocles write about right
sick people acting sick all drama is
that
humans are drawn to the narratives of
other humans
engaged in extreme and usually
pathological behaviors
yeah we don't you know a a healthy
family sitting down at dinner we're
gonna watch that
hell no that's boring it's chaos but the
candle be striking each other in the
head and throwing spaghetti and stuff
we're in we're gonna watch in the human
on a much higher scale yeah because
sometimes it's like are we are we
actually creating bad stuff or are we
just creating exactly what
we really want no it's it the the market
decides and
and and there is where we have
uh the consumer is to blame too because
it goes it goes into a more important
level too
how many stories are you going to see on
cnn or in the new york times about a cop
who [ __ ] risks his life to go into a
a burning building to save a family or a
cop who who dives in front of an open
fire
you know it doesn't it doesn't and that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
happens a lot i've watched with my own
eyes i've watched cops spend
all day trying to counsel [ __ ] crazy
homeless people in venice i watch it
well that's
what happened way more often than the
other stuff within the stuff
but news has become a reality show
narrative it has it's
all wwe it's all turned into wrestling
yeah their narratives are their
narratives they stick with those
narratives
let's get back to a little more sex
before y'all leave because you need help
yeah we all need help uh and nick's been
going through some issues you want to
ask anything personally nick
i actually think they're all pretty good
you're always around he got a girl
nick's been around me for a long time
too right i forget that nick was getting
help before he even got yeah we used to
have private sessions
you know what you're supposed to how
dare you
you know why i love uh adam carrolls
he's one of the only guys right now who
you know he's not on any network tv or
nothing his opinions
he just says it he says it he's always
been that way yeah
and people what's the comedy for me is
and for him too they're always like
dude you've changed that and you've
changed i'm like no i've been with him
the whole time yeah this is this is him
he's always been like this
stay in the same stuff he's just you're
just hearing it now
we have so much disingenuous [ __ ] in
front of our eyes
on camera you know all these celebrities
now who are activists and
adam is the same dude he was when he was
a [ __ ] out of work boxing trainer
yeah you know begging to get on the air
he's the [ __ ] same guy same opinion
that's cool exactly
i love it you know it's interesting too
as you go through life there will be
times where you're a fan of somebody and
the times you're not a fan and the times
where you're a fan again
isn't that pretty fascinating here's
what's above adam you know he's just
being his authentic self is that
we admire that and that's rare and you
have to seek that out well and then he
gets [ __ ] for it lots of us
but he's got to be careful again you
can't cancel him because he's doing his
own show
right it's kind of like trey clay travis
with when it comes sports media
his kick his his opinion
is not the popular opinion you're not
going to see it on espn or fox anything
like that but it
it's really what most of america is
thinking but if he was on espn or
something like that he's gonna get
cancelled
like have you seen what max kellerman
yeah he's saying the sec is full of
stupid people
for playing football all right dude the
majority of people don't think that way
he he's gonna
might he's a [ __ ] bro he couldn't
[ __ ] catch a ball could he
no [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is he talking
about he can rap
he's a white rabbit and he's never grown
up the sec dude people in in the south a
lot of them
would rather they would way rather see a
football game
if they had the last if they're like you
you're going to die they'd be like
that's fine
two days left they'd be like alabama
auburn
it's just what makes them the most hat
it's like saying to somebody in silicon
valley like oh there's a code over there
under that bush or something you know
and and you know what and people don't
experience they look at it from afar and
they [ __ ] judge
you go to norman oklahoma and watch a
game go to [ __ ] go to any go to
georgia
go to alabama go and sit and be in that
stadium experience that
and tell me you don't say like this is
this is it this is living it's also like
this is living
this is also life for them you gotta
imagine if you shut down college
football or those conferences
it has a ripple effect the broadcast and
the advertisers and the people in the
stadium
and the the kids who had a chance to the
nfl you shut all that down it this
ripple effect and people don't even
think of it and
shut it down it's like well hold on
let's look at the actual numbers and the
facts
why would we shut it down and let's not
make a uh emotional decision
and well-being like let's not overlook
that if you're living in oklahoma and
you work your [ __ ] ass off monday
through friday
the fact that you can spend saturday
every all your friends everyone getting
together putting on the red and going
like let's go roll tide there's [ __ ]
a lot of value in that that's you
remember that [ __ ] you know and people
you can't just overlook them that's
important dude it's so
important and to some people it's the
best thing that you do
you know it's the and it's a great thing
man it's interesting in
my family over the years the most
uneducated or what most people would do
deemed the most uneducated are the
happiest people in my family
by far man i mean way happier than
prince is blessed man
yeah it's just crazy and not the most
affluent at all
are they using their hands every day in
their work i feel like yeah i like feel
like people that are engaged in the
world like with their hands
problem solving and building are happier
now than everyone absolutely in their
heads
right there's that episode yeah
when i see him it's like i'll go into
their home and i'll be like man this
home it's
not clean i love it lizards on me and
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying they got
illegal animals in there
but um and they're in there but they're
loving it and their kids are the best
kids right and it's just it and it's not
even i'm saying that because it's my
family i'm just saying
it surprised me it surprised me as i get
older and i get caught up in things and
like man there's
there's a lot there's something i'm
missing about my own joy
because we're in l.a deal i don't know
if it is or not but i don't know
i think it's definitely because i'm
inside of my head let's get to a little
more sex before we get out of here
yeah all right good
because i've refrained from from moving
out of l.a
california is such a goddamn mess fellas
can you get worse
kevin i'm coming from a small town in
illinois
i actually just moved here from cali
finally got the hell out of cali
um i moved to right before lockdown so
yeah just now getting into the dating
scene in this little
midwest new vibe i've got um
and i wanted to get some relationships
where did he move to illinois
little town illinois question is there's
a lot of these country girls
who have kids like some with a lot of
kids
yeah um and uh your boy crushed it
over the last couple weeks i was doing
pretty well take it easy before uh
i just got the rona last week so he got
it yeah
brandon ronald brother's here [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ]
bro made me stronger bro anyway
i'm wondering do i do i go after these
girls who got like
two three kids and hopefully probably
you're done having kids
or do i hold out for that no baggage
hitter
and run the risk that someone's trying
to
pinch uh pinch a little little semen
nugget out of me
all right and uh turning into a human
being so
i want to hear what you guys have to say
gang gang buzz buzz
so so first of all can we we need to
promote the fact that most coronavirus
cases are like you and this guy
that's really the majority of cases
you're fine not literally 99 but the
media wants you to think that
i know is everyone's like i had h1n1
back in 2009 god damn near nearly killed
me
that was like that was horrible that was
some real
yeah and so we need to promote the fact
that this guy you
that that's the face of you you can't
you can't we're doing it if you just let
him do it
but he but he hasn't had corona i you i
i have and he also gets [ __ ] on all the
time
dude that that's all that's in the past
bro yeah
i don't know all the time for trying to
make this point
and you guys are living embodiment of
this point you can see how healthy
everybody everyone's finally got through
the flu
right right my entire family be careful
with mom and dad you know grandma and i
were you brendan yeah and guess what
theo everyone was fine
i knew that yeah i mean listen your
probability of dying of chronovirus if
you're under 35 is .0001
i mean what do i have i have a 10
probability of dying of prostate cancer
i consider my prostate cancer
cured right cured 90 probability of not
dying i i'm in that 90 percent
why is the whole world close it's
because i think i think
i really from the beginning i've been
saying this and i'm saying it again
the press created this panic porn this
panic
and we and we and to be fair to
everybody we didn't quite know what we
were getting into but now it's pretty
clear what this thing is
let's let's behave accordingly let's
learn to live with it and where i'm
asking do our thing
even the news though is backing off
though you don't see a lot of it man
like on the new you really don't see a
lot of it these are no
i'm trying to do other stuff i do a
nightly show on channel 11 here
the fox affiliate like family guy
simpsons kind of fox yeah
and we do a recap every night of what's
going on with coronavirus and uh
we're calming everyone down so we've
been trying to do the whole thing doing
the lord's work man but anyway back to
this guy and his in these women
um he he needs to be careful
because uh people with women with
children
have have um first of all you can date
them right we agree with that he should
be willing to go out with these ladies
ladies yeah but also don't waste their
time don't waste their time because they
may be
needing to get going because they've got
a whole thing going on that they have to
create resources for
and so they may not be looking for a guy
just to date but he can still
see one of the things that bothers me
about dating is everyone puts so much
into it just enjoy another person's
company for dinner
it's okay to do that and hang out and
it's good for you it's
good for you to learn about other people
and learn about your town and enjoy
being attracted to that person but maybe
not going further with her or not being
attracted and learning about yourself
and
whatever it is go hang out with these
people that's fine
but i don't think he should really
engage in any relationships with people
with
with kids unless he wants to raise those
kids i agree that's it period
yep yeah that's a great point i think
there's a yes i don't know i'll put
dating on such a pedestal in my head
like oh i got a date i gotta date them
but
you know it should be just hanging out
just hanging i used to love dating for
that reason when i wasn't like a
resident so i was like this is fun
meeting people yeah experience just
wherever it goes don't worry about it
yeah hey you want to go grab a coffee
sometime make it easy i think sometimes
especially for guys
i noticed for myself i make it so big in
my head yes that it's a hot air balloon
women do it too oh they do yeah yeah
yeah but but again
the hard part is if you're really really
attracted to somebody it's hard not to
do that
yeah but you got to you got to watch
yourself i also think that the the the
value of like that release
where if you're so consumed about like
the end goal
you know i must meet a woman i must meet
a guy it kind of deteriorates from your
ability to just develop yourself
and when you when you really lose sight
of like of i need to get to the finish
line
and just work on becoming a better theo
or becoming a better brennan
you know it's amazing how things kind of
magnetically happen in an interpersonal
context
how you learn you learn about forming
and breaking and
congregating and sharing and move along
yeah
yeah and also somebody you meet that
could just be a friend don't push that
envelope to get that ass
get that titty man yeah because this is
the feel yeah if you get somebody that
just could be a friend they might
introduce you to the love of your life
you know
so keep that mercenary mindset theo is
what he's saying yeah yeah
yeah i think yeah another one nick uh
that's actually about it we're about 90
minutes oh wow that's good man wow yeah
i feel like we're just getting started
we helped nobody
yeah i don't know man i feel better i
always feel better i didn't know that
you guys were so smart i mean i knew
drew was i didn't know michael
mike's smart they're both smart i don't
know about that mike's got some
interesting insights
yeah yeah man he has lived experience
man yes he almost seems like you like he
like you pulled him in out of the uh out
of the uh
practice area i always said like drew
and i
worked because i'm not like cruel i
don't have that acerbic wit or that
insight that corolla has but what i do
have is like
empathy i'm a big drug addict i'm a
serious desperate drug addict
i've had horrible relationships with
women i've had terrible
and great relationships women and i have
a great marriage i like i always said
drew
is a great football player excuse me a
great football coach who never played
but i've got 25 years in the league you
know it's like
and we kind of worked that out that was
going to willy nilly head towards wrap
up with the one story about the woman
you spent the weekend with in vegas
can we help this guy and then go to your
story okay this one broke his dick yeah
this one was very love-lining as well
hey theo brendan mike and drew i work
for fedex and have had some
something very strange happen to me i
pick up a lot of extremely heavy
packages during the day during the
lockdown numbers increased as well as
weight of the packages sometimes when
i'm picking up packages
upwards of a hundred pounds you have to
put your body weight into throwing them
onto shelves of the truck well i had two
very heavy packages catch the edge of
the shelf
and the package and the force of my body
turning into the package smashed my
penis very hard
i have now developed peyronie's disease
from
i am with the love of my life but this
is emasculated and i'm worried she will
become frustrated and leave
and it's there and is there a way for
this to be fixed yeah i'd love to hear
dr
jude's response gang gang broke dick yes
yes you urologist there's a lot to be
done for peyronie's now
all kinds of stuff curable curable no
problem but if he he can affect if he
doesn't get a fix it can affect his
ability to have an erection
it causes pain in your partner during
intercourse it's a mess and it can get
worse it's a it's a scar that forms on
one side of the penis that pulls it in
that direction so you get a big curve
the curve yeah so it's acquired
peyronie's it is quite treatable
what if my penis is kind of shaped like
a candy corn what is that i like that
which direction oh uh skinny part at the
top
that's better probably for wedging yeah
it's like a like
yeah it's like a auger yeah right right
okay yeah
is this the story you wanted to end on
he wanted me to and i always feel
terrible telling it but i went to vegas
it well it's about it gives you example
of what happens
if you're weighing your disease of
addiction and it affects relationships
went to vegas
uh for new year's eve um 2000 into 2001
not the millennium
sure and um i started part it was like
december 29th and we drove out to vegas
and i started
drinking on the way hitting acid eating
sheets of acid and [ __ ]
i remember getting to vegas and then
gambling a little bit and i was like
stumbling and that's all i remember
next thing i know i wake up new year's
day and my friends three days later is
that
like two or three and three days later i
remember like
waking up new year's day my friend
waking me up and he's like we're going
everyone's down at
breakfast let's go eat and i was like
all right [ __ ] so i rolled down there
and there's like a long table of people
that i recognize and it's like a people
on both sides and i walk around i'm like
hey dude hey what's up man right and
then i
start introducing myself to the people i
don't know and i was like hey nice i'm
mike nice to meet you this girl goes
okay
nice guy then i meet go to the end of
the table and i was like hi i'm mike
nice to meet
you and this girl looks at me like i
just killed her puppy
and she walks away like with her head in
her hand i was like what the [ __ ]
and people informed me that not only had
i been
having sex with this girl for the last
couple days but i'd been
parading around las vegas like going on
dates holding hands and like
being romantic and i just introduced
myself to her i
know i felt horrible i still to this day
i talked but i'm like oh my god
damn it's like a movie arachnophobia
have you seen uh have you seen
arachnophilia i have
john goodman yeah yeah i love that movie
me too
it's more like schindler's list but i
get what you're saying
yeah addiction has consequences yeah
yeah it's all bad
man well we thank you guys for coming in
man pleasure
any time honestly it was a great time
blackout dude blm bro
however yeah whatever you do you got to
support it man you know
um we appreciate you guys yeah yeah
thank you guys
my wife said that tell you we just come
on our podcast stream or whatever
i want to sorry so maybe we'll do that
why don't we watch the show i need to
catch up on the show
beyonce and do a uh hello talk where
should we do it it's fantastic idea
where should we stream it or like record
it
do it in a bed in a bed it's pillow
talking yes or a couch you can do a
couch
don't get sued calling it pillow talk
yeah well you have way more bedrooms
than
than i don't think i don't think they
own the name they have a show on
no i'm aware i see it all the time but
it'd be weird and by the way we're
making
it's an homage to them yeah yeah yeah by
the way the pillow talk part is my
wife's favorite part of the night
i prefer it over that right who's your
favorite couple oh i like the couple
who's in florida
the the he's he's super jewish he's our
israeli
israeli yeah they have a new baby they
have the new babies yes
yes this is so oh oh and and i love the
real fat guy in the
thai girl oh super the guy
oh a little weird yeah beautiful little
fella and he's doing cameo you know what
though
he he's he he keeps his sense of humor
about all of it god bless him
god bless him oh have you watched the
the twins new
spin-off yeah i've been subjected to
that that's awesome i think
that is my wife's thing i i am not into
it yeah
sad for those two yeah it's a it's a
tragic right
yeah we're talking about reality it's
tragic
about reality i talk all day about
reality shows man 90 day fiance
nick those are some of the hottest shows
aren't they those covered shows yeah i
uh they're huge the ones just recapping
reality shows or
actually do one yeah let's do it drew
okay fiance would be a great one because
you guys could do it in a series
i'll come do so a couple of episodes
because i'll just be a guest but you
guys could do it i mean i'll do it
we should all do it it'll be great i'm
in i mean it'd be fun to sit and talk
about that
it's so fun it's so entertaining man and
if you guys were just watching it and
pausing
like it could be really low time
investment too it doesn't have to be
like
yeah like we could do a few a whole
whole series of them in different shows
it'd be interesting if we all watched it
even whether we did some of it together
or
separate and then recorded ourselves
watching it and commented it certainly
oh that's good like a reality
like a video and then we have that into
it yeah when we're all together
and here's ed and brittany griner right
here
he's got a little cross there yeah he
has trouble
with the jab done he doesn't he can't
quite pull his shoulder up high enough
oh he's that dude's eating a lot of jabs
bro huh a lot of what
you guys you guys do pillow talk on 90
day fiance we'll do pillow talk about
like browsers
or something no no no
dude i'm i'm out i bet we could get
these people on too
of course you could easily now i want to
do that love on the spectrum autism love
man that's what it
with that i started with that and and i
don't i personally
said something up for me you didn't like
it i'll tell you what i don't like i
don't like those sanctimonious british
talk spo the the australian whatever it
is it's just
it's just here's the zip this is the
soft spoken [ __ ] i just i hate it i
hate it
all right so i can't i couldn't it's too
distracting for me what i liked was the
indian matchmaker
we got to do that one too michael
and i happen to be a 25 year old man
he's great yeah i'll tell you what you
are gonna get
a grade a husband
i love that guy yeah i love him too well
maybe we'll have a new show starting up
[ __ ] yeah that's a good idea mike andrew
thank you guys
[Music]
i gotta go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me
[Music]
up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you